y fue bastante difícil este proceso
porque los demócratas necesitaban el
apoyo de 10 republicanos para llegar a
una cifra mágica de 60 votos 60 votos
sobre 100 que es la totalidad de
asientos que hay en el senado y hasta
contados minutos antes de la votación
los republicanos que se habían reunido
en varias ocasiones durante la tarde
pues no se habían puesto de acuerdo para
asegurarle esos 10 votos que le
permitían entonces a los demócratas ir a
una segunda votación para entonces así
aprobar este hasta este límite de deuda
superior a los 480 mil millones de
dólares que entonces tendrá el gobierno
estadounidense para gastar de aquí al 3
de diciembre
esto al que viene a partir de ahora y
también preguntarte qué representa esto
para eeuu
siempres entonces a partir de ahora lo
que viene es que este proyecto pasará a
la cámara de representantes para la
aprobación de la cámara de
representantes después pasará a despacho
del presidente pero los analistas ven
con preocupación el tema de que en dos
meses a principios de diciembre se tenga
que votar nuevamente este proyecto y
esto cause una nueva disputa entre
republicanos y demócratas en el congreso
y lo que preocupa más aún es que está
aprobación de este nuevo plazo o este
nuevo endeudamiento que se necesitará
para que el gobierno de eeuu siga
operando viene también con la aprobación
para el presupuesto general para evitar
el showdown para evitar el cierre del
gobierno completo entonces se vienen dos
votaciones al mismo tiempo y eso
preocupa además esta votación se daría
justo antes de las vacaciones de acción
de gracias' complicando aún más y
limitando aún más el tiempo de debate y
el tiempo para llegar a un acuerdo para
precisamente pues lograr que este límite
de deuda sea pues se ha aplazado ya en
un tiempo mucho más largo y pues evitar
el cierre el gobierno que se daría
entonces también esta votación en
diciembre a principios de diciembre